[Musique]
times square
sous la neige tempête de neige qui a
complètement paralysé la ville vous
voyez sur ces images fermetures d'écoles
plusieurs centres de vaccination
également à l'arrêt jusqu'à 50 cm de
neige attendues dans les heures qui
viennent
de quoi alimenter la page record des
sites météo américains
de quoi surtout donner à ce coeur de new
york
les allures d'une station de ski et puis
cet homme fait le buzz en ce moment à
new york le naked cowboy le cowboy nu
qui avait que sa guitare a fait le
spectacle sous la neige dans les rues de
new york l'histoire ne dit pas s'il a eu
un petit rhume après cette performance
étonnante y laisser trop sexy c'est trop
chic personnellement moi j'aime cette
année je trouve très chic non non non
non non avec le bouton vert se battre et
je lis ces tendances suis désolé je suis
dans l'intensité
jean michel blanquer le ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui était tout à
l'heure en déplacement dans une école
parisienne oui il était accompagné de
tony estanguet monsieur paris 2024
objectif promouvoir les 30 minutes
d'activités sportives quotidiennes
[Musique]
cette a8 bienvenus
l'internet chinois chen ministre vos
talents de gymnaste ne doivent pas vous
faire oublier l'impératif de faire une
pause sur les mesures de carte scolaire
dans un contexte de crise sans précédent
monsieur le ministre vos talents de
danseur doit vous permet de corriger la
connaissions le début les gens y sont
magnifiques à moi qui ai su jamais
attiré par la couleur il ya du classique
c'est bien fait c'est propre et nette en
birmanie une professeur de sport film
ces exercices matinaux
quand soudain derrière elles débarquent
les camions de militaires qui vont
prendre le contrôle du parlement
sans le savoir et sans s'en rendre
compte elle filme le coup d'état qui va
mener à l'arrestation d'aung san suu kyi
la vidéo est tellement incroyable
qu'elle suscite des doutes pour les
dissiper la jeune femme ou vidéos à
l'appui qu'elle s'entraîne souvent à cet
endroit sur l'avenue qui mène au
parlement
le hasard a fait le reste
monsieur mélenchon je sais bien que la
république si vous me laissez moi un
tout petit moment pour la représenter
quelques instants à vous pouvez hurler
vous vous épuisez pour rien surtout que
la plupart d'entre vous ne savent pas
écrire et respirer en même temps que
j'allais me faire un arrêt cardiaque
monsieur coquerel n'oubliez pas tout à
l'heure la préconisation du médecin
mélenchon qui nous a dit il ne faut pas
crier avec un masque que vous risquez un
infarctus et donc je vous invite à une
grande prudence sur ce sujet là et je
dois dire que vous aurez beau vous
réclamez d'aristide vortex n'est pas
brillant si je peux me permettre
bien souvent les gens qui passent devant
d'autres studios nous regardent à
travers la vitre et dix tiens regarde
moi cette bande de chèvres et
effectivement on nous appelle le studio
était surnommée la chèvrerie pendant 50
ans la conquête spatiale a été l affaire
des gouvernements un instrument de
puissance géopolitique
aujourd'hui c'est celle des entreprises
des start up et des milliardaires jeff
bezos le fondateur d' amazon prévoit de
lancer dès cette année des croisières
touristiques dans l'espace richard
branson et son entreprise virgin
galactic propose déjà de passer quelques
minutes en apesanteur
une société russe veut même créer un
complexe spatial réutilisable pour
accueillir des touristes régulièrement
le nicaragua est une idée un peu comme
votre lancement un peu lunaire et
mystérieux alors garde le pays se
lancent dans la conquête spatiale
en se dotant d'un secrétariat national
aux affaires de l'espace ultra terrestre
à moins que cette fois sur la rue main
pour un pays qui a quand même peu
d'expérience en la matière le trafic
dans le ciel promet donc d'être dense et
c'est pour cela qu'un ancien patron de
l'agencé spatiale européenne plaide pour
la création d'un code de la route de
l'espace mieux pour régler les litiges
commerciaux liés à ces activités
dubaï a annoncé hier la mise en place
d'un tribunal de l'espace que les pays
où les entreprises pourront saisir
directement
aujourd'hui le droit spatial et d'un
autre temps il est régie par un traité
signé à l'onu en 1967
ces policiers pour partie d'une nouvelle
unité dans l'air du temps
les bikers agression le vélo est plus
qu'un simple moyen de déplacement il
devient une arme de dissuasion
alors cette appli il peut même servir de
bouclier
[Musique]
et c'est quoi cette chaussure alors là
franchement j'ai pas de mots non mais ça
va pas la tête ou quoi
bah oui vous ferai attention blé vie
vous avez des poissons de mort au pied
le poisson vous passez du poisson chat
tu vois non thème path enceinte je
manger halal et jamais vu une chaussure
position dans ma vie je suis pêcheur et
donc du coup j'étais pense beaucoup dans
la pêche je passe beaucoup de temps à la
pêche et cetera donc c'est vrai que
c'est une passion qui prend énormément
de temps
il a les mains dans les poches c'est
d'attraper une truite ou non ces gangs
sont dingues en latex on aime à l'homme
ça c'est pour me toucher le soir
tranquillement dans ma chambre
oui bien sûr d'accord ok a songé
masturbation féminine on est là on y va
quand vous l'avez rencontré vous étiez
célibataire si j'étais célibataire même
si j'avais un petit coup sur la main le
soir même du coussoul à moi j'étais avec
quelqu'un me dit c'est quoi le soir
d'été comme ça fulham en commun
ouais bon gros noms mais vous le dites
je me lave pas pippa banqueroute
oui mais je vis tous les jours
artix fier quand vous écrivez leila
slimani pour chansons douces prix
goncourt 2016
je me lève à laver les cônes en l'être
humain qu'en c1 sera un public sera fait
mais c'est étonnant quand même d'être
humains parce que c'est en fait la
situation conditionne le comportement
philosophie oui je me lave peu je me
nourris mal tué ma mère
benjamin biolay bonjour himal c'est vrai
bon ben voilà au moins j'ai une règle je
me lave bien
alors moi moi je mange pas beaucoup
quand j'écris c'est vrai mais je change
de cale barre jeudi j'ai terminé mon
travail bien travaillé c'est super allez
on y va
il est beau
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]